today it's my first day at high school I
can't believe I'm finally here
I'm cutie pie my dear and did this
master for yes I joined to become a
youtuber and I'm finally here at YouTube
high school hey you what was that baby
baby I'm Tanya burr what's your name
Marcia I mean cutie pie yet oh you must
be new here let me show you around
follow me baby
why was that potato talking to me oh
well I better follow
stress you can see this is the insider
it scared what was the hair fangers he
must be near Perry Perry who's that just
wait you're a founder all right I'm
happy take my picture all right listen
mate make sure I look [ __ ] good or
I'll [ __ ] kill you
how's the pictures going babe radda
radda radda right how you doing sir why
don't you join me in this picture
section
I'll be fine just you in it she's doing
me okay Wow
Wow they must be super famous or
something yes they have millions of
subscribers you know I have a cup of
Mel's my fave Maddow Services pittypat
guy you were talking about don't worry
you'll see him or I mean hear him soon
in it
that's the clash man we better get going
baby man oh oh what what what what what
what's coming down over there no way
you best believe in them and learn what
what what's the matter Dan I mean feel
it's there's something wrong you seem so
tense
oh it it's nothing I was just
questioning why we do this [ __ ] every
day
sure we get a lot of juice and a lot of
money and a lot of fingers but really in
the end does it really matter
Oh Dan I mean feel just relax let me
take care of it
all right baby baby what are you guys
doing
back off lady unless you don't know
what's good for yourself great you're
scared him away well I best be goin in
okay but sit with that beer I mean dad a
[ __ ] I can't get him a pot I got I
gotta go I'm sorry I can't I can't
Wow she's so weird well I better take a
seat excuse me I think you're in my spot
hey and I don't know what your [ __ ]
you're saying take it the [ __ ] outta me
think
all right I'm a cure but if it innit
who would ever date an idiot like that
oh my god I'm back all right class is
about to start and here we have a new
teacher hey super had no no door no no
no ho whoa oh oh oh oh boy that sure was
a quick class beard I'm a guy not this
[ __ ] idiot again you seem new around
here what I could show you around
barrels would that be nice yeah okay I
get
let's go edit it edit it now that I
didn't
Wow you made it automatic first yes I
think I love you I think I love you too
will you marry me okay
I mean no I can't we just met I give you
this pug baby bit bit bit bit what Oh
what
her why did you say so and so the
YouTube power couple lived happily ever
after but this was just one story of
many others in YouTube high school whose
story do you want to hear next leave a
comment down below perhaps
hey guys what a mess